das fbi ermittelt jetzt offiziell gegen
chance engstes umfeld wegen der russland
kontakte und er reagiert natürlich wie
immer mit einem feuerwerk aus
nebelkerzen und lügen
wie denn auch sonst so hat das gelernt
trampe
[Applaus]
eine heiße sache gewesen
wer träumt er doch von politik überhaupt
keine ahnung wirklich 04 jetzt nicht im
heute stoffe ein job das neue buch für
kleine präsidenten mit da lerne alles
was du über diese komplizierte welt
wittenburg beispiel über den klimawandel
das ist die sonne die wackelbrücke
deshalb macht der nordpol schmilzt
schnell lernen spielerisch an welchen
stellen du eine fremde frau antworten
darf
[Musik]
toll für kinder ab 3 jahre und 2
[Applaus]